This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. There was a time when most detective stories featured the brilliant insights of a genius. Sherlock Holmes and Miss Marple noticed clues the rest of us didn't and solved mysteries using little more than their eyes and their intuition. In the story, The Adventure of the Blue Carbuncle, Sherlock Holmes inspects a hat that was found next to a stolen gem. He tells his friend, John Watson, that the hat's owner is a smart, formerly wealthy man who recently turned evil. He is middle-aged, out of shape, recently cut his hair, and his wife no longer loves him.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。曾几何时，大多数侦探故事都以天才的敏锐洞察力为特色。夏洛克·福尔摩斯和马普尔小姐能注意到我们其他人忽略的线索，并仅凭双眼和直觉解决谜题。在《蓝宝石探案》的故事中，夏洛克·福尔摩斯检查了一顶在被盗宝石旁发现的帽子。他告诉他的朋友约翰·华生，帽子的主人是一个聪明、曾经富有但最近变坏了的男人。他中年、身材走样、刚剪了头发，而且他的妻子不再爱他了。
All of this from simply looking at the hat. In the real world, crime solving today relies less on sharp eyes and intuitive leaps, and more on the science of forensics. more on the science of forensics. Suspects leave fingerprints at scenes of crime, and tiny strands of DNA can identify one person out of billions. In recent years, psychologists have gotten into the game. They have discovered another set of clues
所有这些信息仅仅通过观察帽子就能得出。在现实世界中，今天的犯罪侦破不再那么依赖敏锐的眼睛和直觉的飞跃，而是更多地依赖法医学。犯罪嫌疑人在犯罪现场留下指纹，微小的DNA链就能从数十亿人中识别出一个人。近年来，心理学家也加入了这场游戏。他们发现了另一组线索，
that can give us a window into a suspect's mind. The source of this hidden information? Language. The words we use in both speech and writing reveal a lot about us. They can give us insight into a potential criminal, yes, but also whether someone is depressed, when a person is lying, even how long a lover will remain in a romantic relationship. What your pronouns and prepositions really say about you. This week on Hidden Brain. Have you ever gotten a confusing message from a friend or family member? Maybe a text or email.
这些线索可以让我们窥见嫌疑人的内心世界。这些隐藏信息的来源是什么？语言。我们在说话和写作中使用的词汇揭示了关于我们的很多信息。它们不仅能让我们洞察潜在的罪犯，还能判断某人是否抑郁、何时在撒谎，甚至恋人还能维持多久的浪漫关系。你的代词和介词真正说明了关于你的什么。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。你是否曾经收到过朋友或家人发来的令人困惑的信息？也许是一条短信或电子邮件。
You read it and realize, I have no idea what this person is actually feeling. If only there was a way to decipher what she really means. In recent years, scientists have tried to do exactly that. They find that if we pay close attention to the patterns in speech and writing, we can understand profound things about others and even ourselves. At the University of Texas at Austin, psychologist James Pennebaker has spent decades studying how the words we use can be an X-ray into our minds. Jamie Pennebaker, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's nice to be here,
你读了之后意识到，我根本不知道这个人到底是什么感觉。如果有一种方法能解读她真正的意思就好了。近年来，科学家们试图做到这一点。他们发现，如果我们密切关注说话和写作中的模式，我们就能理解关于他人甚至我们自己的深刻事物。在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，心理学家詹姆斯·彭尼贝克花了数十年时间研究我们使用的词汇如何成为我们思想的X光片。杰米·彭尼贝克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里，
thank you. Jamie, early on in your career you were studying how writing can help people get over traumatic experiences, but as part of that research you noticed something. The language people use changed as their mental states changed. Can you tell me how this discovery unfolded? I was trying to figure out why is it that writing about an upsetting experience can improve people's health? And it occurred to me, I needed a more objective way to look at essays.
谢谢。杰米，在你职业生涯的早期，你研究的是写作如何帮助人们克服创伤性经历，但作为那项研究的一部分，你注意到了一些事情。人们使用的语言随着他们心理状态的变化而变化。你能告诉我这个发现是如何展开的吗？我当时试图弄清楚，为什么写下令人不安的经历可以改善人们的健康？我意识到，我需要一种更客观的方法来审视这些文章。
And so I looked for a computer program to analyze the text. And I ended up asking one of my graduate students to help put together a computer program that can analyze language. And it was that program that allowed us to all of a sudden start to see writing samples in ways that I had never imagined we'd be able to do. The computer program that Jamie developed could analyze a text, breaking it down by word choice, parts of speech, and meaning. Take the sentence, it was a dark and stormy night.
所以我寻找了一个计算机程序来分析文本。最终，我让我的一名研究生帮忙编写了一个可以分析语言的计算机程序。正是那个程序让我们突然开始以我从未想象过的方式观察写作样本。杰米开发的计算机程序可以分析文本，通过词汇选择、词性分析和含义进行拆解。以这句话为例：那是一个黑暗而风雨交加的夜晚。
The program would categorize the word it as a pronoun. The word was would be counted as a verb. Stormy is an adjective. After developing this program, Jamie then brought volunteers into the lab and asked them to give him writing samples. He analyzed their writing through the computer program and then compared the results to the personalities of the writers. He came to several astonishing conclusions. One of the first was that men and women employ language differently.
程序会将“it”这个词归类为代词。“was”这个词会被算作动词。“stormy”是一个形容词。开发出这个程序后，杰米把志愿者带进实验室，让他们提供写作样本。他通过计算机程序分析了他们的写作，然后将结果与作者的性格进行了比较。他得出了几个惊人的结论。其中第一个结论是，男性和女性使用语言的方式不同。
Jamie assumed that men are more likely than women to act in boastful ways. So he expected they would refer a lot to themselves. I. They would use a lot of words like I. Me. Me and my. My. Jamie figured women would use a lot of words like I, me, and my.
杰米假设男性比女性更有可能以自夸的方式行事。所以他预计他们会大量提及自己。我。他们会使用很多像“我”、“我”、“我的”这样的词。杰米认为女性会使用很多像“我”、“我”和“我的”这样的词。
Jamie figured women would use words like we more often. The most striking early discovery was that looking at men and women, they used language in ways that made no sense to me. I found that women used I words, I, me, and my, much higher rates than men. Me, my. I expected big differences in the use of we, but in fact men and women use we words at the same rates. We.
杰米认为女性会更频繁地使用“我们”这样的词。最早最引人注目的发现是，观察男性和女性时，他们使用语言的方式让我感到莫名其妙。我发现女性使用“我”类词汇——“我”、“我”和“我的”——的频率远高于男性。我，我的。我预计在“我们”的使用上会有巨大差异，但事实上，男性和女性使用“我们”类词汇的频率是一样的。我们。
Us. Our. And there were these other parts of speech that were just very different and I had no idea what they meant. And over the years we did more and more studies and part of it was men and women are paying attention to the world differently. Women are looking and are more interested in other human beings and by definition definition, if you're interested in human beings, you have to use pronouns. He.
我们。我们的。还有其他一些词性非常不同，我根本不知道它们意味着什么。多年来，我们做了越来越多的研究，部分原因是男性和女性对世界的关注点不同。女性在观察时对其他人更感兴趣，根据定义，如果你对人类感兴趣，你就必须使用代词。他。
Words like he, she, they, we, I, etc. She. They. And if you're interested in objects and things, which men tend to be, you use nouns and articles. A. A. N. V. V. use nouns and articles and prepositions to a four. And so all of a sudden I realized the world was way more complex than I ever thought.
像“他”、“她”、“他们”、“我们”、“我”等等这样的词。她。他们。如果你对物体和事物感兴趣，而男性往往如此，你就会使用名词和冠词。一个。一个。N。V。V。使用名词、冠词和介词。所以突然之间，我意识到世界比我想象的要复杂得多。
I confess I was skeptical about these conclusions. There are all kinds of pop psychology claims about gender differences that mostly rely on stereotypes about men and women. But then Jamie told me about another dimension of this research. It had an experimental quality to it. It tracked individuals getting supplements of testosterone, the primary male sex hormone. Testosterone seems to affect the way we see our world. And several years ago, working with Jim Dabbs and others who had been doing work on testosterone,
我承认我对这些结论持怀疑态度。关于性别差异的各种流行心理学主张大多依赖于关于男性和女性的刻板印象。但后来杰米告诉了我这项研究的另一个维度。它具有实验性质。它追踪了接受睾酮（主要的男性性激素）补充剂的个体。睾酮似乎影响了我们看待世界的方式。几年前，与吉姆·达布斯和其他一直在研究睾酮的人合作，
we were able to study a person who was transitioning from female to male and was taking periodic injections of testosterone. I was studying this person's diaries over time, and trying to find out when this person took the testosterone injections, did their language change? I was telling a friend of this,
我们能够研究一个正在从女性向男性过渡并定期注射睾酮的人。我一直在研究这个人的日记，试图找出当这个人注射睾酮时，他们的语言是否发生了变化？我当时正告诉一位朋友这件事，
and this friend was an academic, and he was saying, wow, that's weird, I've been taking testosterone as well because he had moved to a farm and he was older by this time and he started taking testosterone to increase his upper body strength. And I asked him, would he mind sharing when he had taken these shots and also sharing his outgoing emails for the previous year.
这位朋友是一位学者，他说，哇，那太奇怪了，我也一直在服用睾酮，因为他搬到了一个农场，而且当时年纪大了，他开始服用睾酮来增加上半身的力量。我问他，他是否介意分享他注射的时间，以及分享他过去一年的外发邮件。
So for both of them, I could look at when they took shots, which was usually about once every three weeks, and how their language changed from before taking the testosterone to the three weeks afterwards. And I found the same kind of changes. And it was not what either of them expected at all. And that was when the individuals took the testosterone shots, they started using pronouns,
所以对于他们两人，我都可以观察他们注射的时间（通常大约每三周一次），以及他们的语言从注射前到注射后三周发生了怎样的变化。我发现了同样的变化。这完全出乎他们两人的意料。那就是当个人注射睾酮时，他们开始以较低的频率使用代词，
he, she, they, etc. at lower rates. It's almost as though they became less interested in other human beings. Testosterone then didn't make people talk more about power or aggression or anger or anxiety or anything. There was no differences there. Only this lack of interest in humans after taking a testosterone shot. Jamie had discovered that the language people use reveals something about what is happening inside their heads. Words reflect not just what we are trying to communicate, but how we see the world, how we see each other. Fascinated, Jamie started using his language analysis tool to study other facets of human behavior. He quickly noticed a group of words that was extremely important, but these are not words
“他”、“她”、“他们”等等。就好像他们对其他人变得不那么感兴趣了。睾酮并没有让人谈论更多关于权力、攻击性、愤怒、焦虑或任何其他事情。这方面没有差异。只有在注射睾酮后对人类缺乏兴趣。杰米发现，人们使用的语言揭示了他们大脑内部正在发生的事情。词汇不仅反映了我们试图传达的内容，还反映了我们如何看待世界，如何看待彼此。杰米很着迷，开始使用他的语言分析工具来研究人类行为的其他方面。他很快注意到一组非常重要的词，但这些词并不是
most people would think are important. I focus a lot on a group of words called function words. These are the words you learned in high school. They're the most boring words in language. They include pronouns. He. She. They. Negations, no, not, never, prepositions, auxiliary verbs, am, is. All of these are words that don't have any solid meaning like a noun does or a verb or adjective does. What I started to discover was it
大多数人认为重要的词。我非常关注一组被称为功能词的词。这些是你高中学过的词。它们是语言中最无聊的词。它们包括代词。“他”、“她”、“他们”。否定词，“不”、“没有”、“从不”，介词，助动词，“am”、“is”。所有这些都是没有任何具体含义的词，不像名词、动词或形容词那样。我开始发现的是，
was these function words, which are telling us how people are seeing in the world, how they're negotiating with others, how they're thinking about themselves and others. And with this, we can start to get a picture of their personality, if you like. So for example, I could go out to your listening audience, ask them to send me their, you know, their last two or three emails that they sent out. And people who use a high number of pronouns like he, she, they, you, etc., those people are more socially connected.
正是这些功能词，告诉我们人们是如何看待世界的，他们是如何与他人协商的，他们是如何思考自己和他人的。有了这个，我们就可以开始描绘他们的性格，如果你愿意的话。例如，我可以去找你们的听众，让他们把他们发送的最后两三封电子邮件发给我。那些使用大量代词（如“他”、“她”、“他们”、“你”等）的人，在社交上联系更紧密。
They're more interested in other human beings. She is one of those people who will maintain composure in the situation. I can't believe he did that. You're super smart, you're funny, you know what you're doing. I trust you. Or another interesting one is people who are anxious. Now, a person who's anxious will use anxiety related words, words like worry, upset, nervous, but they're also very much self-focused
他们对其他人更感兴趣。她是那种在那种情况下能保持冷静的人。我不敢相信他做了那种事。你超级聪明，你很有趣，你知道你在做什么。我相信你。或者另一个有趣的例子是焦虑的人。现在，一个焦虑的人会使用与焦虑相关的词，比如“担心”、“不安”、“紧张”，但他们也非常自我关注，
and they tend to use pronouns like I, I, me, and my, I refer to as I words. I at much higher rate than people who are not anxious. And in fact, all of us when we're anxious, we start using more I words. And the same thing is true of depression. Any emotion that makes us look inward, we will start using I words more. And even if we're physically sick or in pain, we use I words more. In other
并且他们倾向于使用像“我”、“我”和“我的”这样的代词，我称之为“我”类词汇。我使用的频率比不焦虑的人高得多。事实上，我们所有人在焦虑时，都会开始使用更多的“我”类词汇。抑郁症也是如此。任何让我们向内看的负面情绪，都会让我们开始更多地使用“我”类词汇。即使我们身体生病或感到疼痛，我们也会更多地使用“我”类词汇。换句话说，
words, I words are reflecting self-focus. Hmm. Hmm. I mean, what's striking here, Jamie, is that I think when most people think about language, they think about words that have, you know, an affective quality. I'm excited, I'm happy, I'm sad, I'm I'm moody. But what you're really finding is that it's almost the connective tissue between words that actually reveals the inner workings of our minds. That's exactly the way I think about it is these words, what I love about them is they're invisible. We can't hear them. We can't control them very well, but they are revealing parts of ourselves that we just didn't know that we were, you know, that we were spilling those beans.
“我”类词汇反映了自我关注。嗯。嗯。杰米，这里引人注目的是，我认为当大多数人想到语言时，他们想到的是具有情感色彩的词。我很兴奋，我很开心，我很悲伤，我情绪化。但你真正发现的是，实际上是词与词之间的连接组织揭示了我们思想的内在运作。这正是我的想法，我喜欢这些词的地方在于它们是隐形的。我们听不到它们。我们无法很好地控制它们，但它们正在揭示我们自己都不知道的、我们正在泄露的秘密。
What is striking about these function words is how few there are and how often we use them. They're not that many in the English language. There are only about 200 common ones. But we use these function words at very high rates. For example, these pronouns, prepositions and articles, etc. account for about 60% of all the words we say, we hear. Wow. The majority of words you and I have spoken have been function words in this conversation and we don't even know it. I confess I was skeptical about these conclusions. They're invisible.
这些功能词引人注目之处在于它们的数量很少，而且我们使用它们的频率很高。英语中并没有那么多。只有大约200个常用的。但我们以非常高的频率使用这些功能词。例如，这些代词、介词和冠词等占了我们所说、所听到的所有词汇的约60%。哇。你和我在这段对话中说的大部分词都是功能词，我们甚至都没有意识到。我承认我对这些结论持怀疑态度。它们是隐形的。
We can't hear them. We can understand profound things about others and even ourselves. All of these function words together are so powerful because they are telling us about our social orientation if we're looking inward. A lot of it is telling us where we're paying attention and how we're thinking and what our connections with others are. So one thing that I want to point out and flag is that the differences in the rate at which these words are used can be subtle. So it's not as if you can listen to someone's conversation intuitively and pick up that
我们听不到它们。我们可以理解关于他人甚至我们自己的深刻事物。所有这些功能词加在一起非常强大，因为它们告诉我们关于我们的社会取向，即我们是否在向内看。其中很大一部分告诉我们我们在哪里投入了注意力，我们是如何思考的，以及我们与他人的联系是什么。所以我想指出并标记的一件事是，使用这些词的频率差异可能是微妙的。所以并不是说你可以直觉地听出某人的谈话并察觉到
the fact that they're using more of these kinds of function words or fewer of these function words. In some ways, these have to be analyzed almost at a statistical level. That's right. A good example is people who are depressed use I words at higher rate than when they're not depressed. And when they're depressed in, let's say, a regular conversation, they might use maybe six percent of their words might be I words.
他们正在使用更多或更少这类功能词的事实。在某些方面，这些几乎必须在统计层面上进行分析。没错。一个很好的例子是，抑郁的人使用“我”类词汇的频率比不抑郁时要高。当他们抑郁时，比如在正常的谈话中，他们可能会使用大约6%的“我”类词汇。
If they're not depressed, it could be four percent or five percent., it sounds like the difference between 4% and 6% is trivial, and on one level it is, but as it happens, it's a huge statistical effect because people don't vary a lot in terms of their use of these. So it is a really powerful marker that we just can't hear. On one level, given that language is a product of the mind, it's not surprising that our words should reflect the patterns in our thinking. But Jamie is reverse engineering the process. He is looking at our words and inferring what is happening in our minds. Used this way, words become a sort of x-ray into our thinking.
如果他们不抑郁，可能是4%或5%。听起来4%和6%之间的差异微不足道，在某种程度上确实如此，但事实证明，这是一个巨大的统计效应，因为人们在使用这些词方面并没有太大的差异。所以这是一个我们听不到的非常强大的标记。在某种程度上，鉴于语言是大脑的产物，我们的词汇应该反映我们思维模式并不令人惊讶。但杰米正在对这个过程进行逆向工程。他正在观察我们的词汇并推断我们大脑中正在发生的事情。以这种方式使用，词汇就成了我们思维的一种X光片。
Jimmy cautions that this is a diagnostic tool, not a magic wand. You're probably wondering, well, if I could get people to, let's say, if we know that I words are associated with depression, can we get a depressed person to stop using I words and they'd be happy? LAUGHS
杰米告诫说，这是一种诊断工具，而不是魔杖。你可能在想，好吧，如果我能让人们，假设我们知道“我”类词汇与抑郁症有关，我们能让一个抑郁的人停止使用“我”类词汇，他们就会快乐吗？（笑声）
By the way the answer is no. It does not work that way. Yeah so it's not as if you can actually manipulate the words you're using temporarily and suddenly dramatically change your mind states. It's really the words that you're using automatically almost unconsciously that are really telling you something about what's happening inside your head. That's exactly right. So for example, one thing that happens is when people assume a leadership role, they use I words less, but they tend to use we words, we, us, and our more.
顺便说一句，答案是否定的。它不是那样工作的。是的，所以并不是说你可以暂时操纵你使用的词汇，然后突然戏剧性地改变你的心理状态。真正告诉你大脑内部正在发生什么的，其实是你自动、几乎无意识地使用的词汇。完全正确。例如，当人们担任领导角色时，他们会减少使用“我”类词汇，但他们倾向于更多地使用“我们”类词汇——“我们”、“我们”和“我们的”。
In other words, you take on the mantle of leadership and you are now looking out at others. You're not paying attention to yourself, which by the way is opposite of what most of us think. But years ago we did some studies where we were able to induce people to use we words more. Did they become leaders? No. Did they feel more connected to others?
换句话说，你承担了领导的重任，你现在正在向外看他人。你没有关注自己，顺便说一句，这与我们大多数人的想法相反。但几年前我们做了一些研究，我们能够诱导人们更多地使用“我们”类词汇。他们成为领导者了吗？没有。他们感到与他人联系更紧密了吗？
No. It made no difference. But if we induced them to become leaders, they then started using I words less and we words more. So about a decade ago, Jamie, you became fascinated by the story of an explorer in rural Australia. Tell me the story of Henry Hellyer. So Henry Hellyer was a British explorer. He was born in the late 1700s in England and
没有。这没有任何区别。但如果我们诱导他们成为领导者，他们就开始减少使用“我”类词汇，更多地使用“我们”类词汇。所以大约十年前，杰米，你对澳大利亚农村一位探险家的故事着迷了。告诉我们亨利·赫利尔的故事。亨利·赫利尔是一位英国探险家。他出生于18世纪末的英国，
then emigrated to Australia and he was interested in discovery and he went to Tasmania. Tasmania is an island about the size of England in southern Australia, about 150 miles from from the Australia mainland. And he had written in root on this trip, he had written several long journals, he had written lots of letters and so forth. So Henry Hellyer was known as a very clever and intelligent man, and he also wrote about his adventures as he was having them. One entry he noted on August 9th 1827 went, We have had a very stormy night. Just before dark, the men saw a tree falling directly towards my tent. I had just time to run out being apprised
后来移民到澳大利亚，他对发现感兴趣，并去了塔斯马尼亚。塔斯马尼亚是澳大利亚南部的一个岛屿，大小与英国相当，距离澳大利亚大陆约150英里。他在这次旅行的途中写了几本长篇日记，写了很多信件等等。所以亨利·赫利尔被认为是一个非常聪明和有才华的人，他也记录了他冒险时的经历。他在1827年8月9日的一条记录中写道：“我们度过了一个非常风雨交加的夜晚。就在天黑前，男人们看到一棵树直接倒向我的帐篷。我刚来得及跑出来，因为他们的喊叫声提醒了我，
of the danger by their shouting, and the next instant my poor tent and porch of bark were laid prostrate. Had it been dark, I could not have escaped." So it sounds like he was having a real adventure here, Jamie. He was, and his relatives who got these letters picked that up as well. But then things, two or three years after that, started to go oddly. There seemed to be some tension between him and the other men on his party. He then died. And in the years afterwards,
下一刻，我可怜的帐篷和树皮门廊就被压平了。如果天黑了，我就无法逃脱了。”听起来他在这里经历了一场真正的冒险，杰米。确实如此，收到这些信件的亲戚们也注意到了这一点。但后来，两三年后，事情开始变得奇怪。他和队伍中的其他人之间似乎出现了一些紧张关系。然后他去世了。在随后的几年里，
there was increasing questions about this. Was it suicide? Was he murdered? And I'll be honest, I had never heard of Henry Hellyer, but I often get emails from people all over the world who have some interesting case they're trying to work on. And one of the people that I heard from was a woman by the name of Gwyneth Daniel, who was interested in Hellyer. And she wanted to know what I thought of his letters and where his letters consisted with suicide.
人们对此产生了越来越多的疑问。是自杀吗？他是被谋杀的吗？老实说，我以前从未听说过亨利·赫利尔，但我经常收到来自世界各地的人发来的电子邮件，他们有一些试图解决的有趣案例。我听到的其中一个人是一位名叫格温妮丝·丹尼尔的女士，她对赫利尔很感兴趣。她想知道我对他的信件有什么看法，以及他的信件是否符合自杀的特征。
Jamie analyzed Henry Hellyer's letters. He put them through his computer program and counted the function words and non-function words. He also drew on some earlier work he had done comparing two groups of poets. The first group was writers who had died by suicide. The writers in the second group were roughly comparable to the first group, but had not died by suicide. Did the first group refer more often
杰米分析了亨利·赫利尔的信件。他把它们放进他的计算机程序中，计算了功能词和非功能词。他还利用了他之前所做的一些比较两组诗人的工作。第一组是自杀身亡的作家。第二组的作家与第一组大致相当，但没有自杀。第一组是否更频繁地提及
to depression and death in their poems? In fact, there was virtually no difference in their content. The big differences surrounded pronouns, specifically I words, that suicidal poets used I words at much higher rates in their poetry than non-suicidal. That was what I was interested in looking at Hellyer's writing. If he was depressive in his writing over time, did his use of I words start to increase? And that's what we looked at. And indeed, they increased dramatically.
抑郁和死亡在他们的诗歌中？事实上，他们的内容几乎没有区别。巨大的差异围绕着代词，特别是“我”类词汇，即自杀诗人诗歌中“我”类词汇的使用率远高于非自杀诗人。这就是我感兴趣去观察赫利尔写作的地方。如果他随着时间的推移在写作中表现出抑郁，他使用“我”类词汇的频率是否开始增加？这就是我们所观察到的。确实，它们急剧增加。
In the first two or three years of his explorations, his average number of I words was about 1% of all of his words. He was so immersed in the world around him. And in the last year, in the last maybe three or four writings, they averaged a much higher rate between eight and ten percent of all of his words. He was deeply, deeply self-focused, which tells me there was a very good chance he died of suicide.
在他探险的前两三年里，“我”类词汇的平均数量约占他所有词汇的1%。他完全沉浸在他周围的世界中。而在最后一年，在最后三四篇写作中，它们的平均使用率要高得多，占他所有词汇的8%到10%。他非常、非常自我关注，这告诉我他很有可能是自杀身亡的。
side. Jamie had discovered that the words people use can give us insights into their minds. When we come back, Jamie applies his research to a complicated murder case. First though, a quick note to say that if you or someone you love is struggling with suicidal thoughts, there are people who can help. You can call, text or chat with the Suicide and Crisis Lifeline at 988. That number again is 988. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
杰米发现，人们使用的词汇可以让我们洞察他们的内心。回来后，杰米将他的研究应用到一个复杂的谋杀案中。不过首先，简单提醒一下，如果你或你爱的人正在与自杀念头作斗争，有人可以提供帮助。你可以拨打、发送短信或在线聊天联系自杀与危机生命线，号码是988。再说一遍，号码是988。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the University of Texas at Austin, James Pennebaker has spent many years studying what our choice of words can reveal about us. He's found subtle differences in how we use words when we are happy, depressed, angry or friendly. Often, words we think of as insignificant provide important clues about our inner states of mind. Jimmy, a few years ago you received a request asking for your expertise in a murder case in Australia that involved a woman named Kathleen Folbig. Now, Kathleen and
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，詹姆斯·彭尼贝克花了多年时间研究我们选择的词汇能揭示关于我们的什么。他发现我们在快乐、抑郁、愤怒或友好时使用词汇的方式存在细微差别。通常，我们认为微不足道的词汇提供了关于我们内心心理状态的重要线索。杰米，几年前你收到一个请求，要求你在澳大利亚一起涉及一名叫凯瑟琳·福尔比格的女性的谋杀案中提供专业知识。现在，凯瑟琳和
her husband Craig welcomed their first child in 1989. Obviously, this was a happy moment in the life of any family, but what came next was a tragedy. Can you tell me the story of what happened, Jamie? So their first child, Caleb, was born and the child was about three weeks old and one night Craig woke up in the middle of the night hearing her screaming and Kathleen was screaming that something was the matter, the baby wasn't moving. And Craig ran into the room and saw her standing over the child.
她的丈夫克雷格在1989年迎来了他们的第一个孩子。显然，这是任何家庭生活中快乐的时刻，但接下来发生的是一场悲剧。你能告诉我发生了什么事吗，杰米？他们的第一个孩子凯莱布出生了，孩子大约三周大，一天晚上克雷格在半夜醒来，听到她在尖叫，凯瑟琳尖叫着说出事了，婴儿不动了。克雷格跑进房间，看到她站在孩子身上。
And the child wasn't breathing and they called an ambulance and the child who was only just 20 days old was dead. And the official cause of death was Sid's sudden infant death. And of course that has been known to happen to children, I think especially if they're placed on their stomachs. We know much more about Sid's today than perhaps they did in the late 80s. And I'm imagining that Kathleen and Craig experienced this as a great tragedy. Tell me what happened next. Did they recover? Did they have more children, Jamie? They did, and ultimately
孩子没有呼吸，他们叫了救护车，那个只有20天大的孩子死了。官方死因是婴儿猝死综合症（SIDS）。当然，众所周知，这种情况会发生在孩子身上，我想特别是如果他们被放在肚子上睡觉的话。我们今天对SIDS的了解比80年代末可能要多得多。我想象凯瑟琳和克雷格将此视为一场巨大的悲剧。告诉我接下来发生了什么。他们恢复了吗？他们还有更多的孩子吗，杰米？他们有了，最终
they had three more children, and each child died usually within a few months of birth. The last one survived for one year, about a year and a half. So this was over essentially a 10-year period. It's difficult to imagine what Craig and Kathleen Folbig endured during those 10 years, as they brought children into the world and lost them again and again. Eventually, the weight of these tragedies tore the couple apart and they divorced. Kathleen moved out. Sometime later, as he was cleaning the house, Craig stumbled upon several of Kathleen's
他们又有了三个孩子，每个孩子通常在出生后几个月内就去世了。最后一个活了一年，大约一年半。所以这基本上是超过10年的时间。很难想象克雷格和凯瑟琳·福尔比格在这10年里忍受了什么，因为他们把孩子带到这个世界上，又一次又一次地失去他们。最终，这些悲剧的重压使这对夫妇分崩离析，他们离婚了。凯瑟琳搬走了。一段时间后，当克雷格打扫房子时，他偶然发现了凯瑟琳的几本
diaries. They revealed a conflicted woman. She was excited by motherhood and loved her children. But she also felt frustrated, resentful, fearful, and jealous. Reading the entries, Craig became alarmed. Some entries implied that Kathleen was struggling with unresolved mental health issues. In one entry she wrote, Another, referring to her daughter Sarah, said simply, "...with Sarah, all I wanted was her to shut up." And one day she did.
日记。它们揭示了一个矛盾的女人。她对为人母感到兴奋，爱她的孩子。但她也感到沮丧、怨恨、恐惧和嫉妒。读着这些条目，克雷格感到震惊。一些条目暗示凯瑟琳正在与未解决的心理健康问题作斗争。在其中一个条目中，她写道，另一个，指的是她的女儿莎拉，简单地说，“……对于莎拉，我只想让她闭嘴。”有一天她真的闭嘴了。
Craig took the diaries to the police. Kathleen Folbig was arrested and tried for the murder of her own children. She maintained she was innocent, but she was found guilty, based in part on the diary evidence. Years passed. Kathleen appealed her conviction, but was turned down. That's when Jamie got involved. I was contacted by her lawyer.
克雷格把日记交给了警察。凯瑟琳·福尔比格被捕并因谋杀自己的孩子而受审。她坚称自己是无辜的，但她被判有罪，部分依据是日记证据。岁月流逝。凯瑟琳对她的定罪提出上诉，但被驳回。就在那时，杰米介入了。我被她的律师联系了。
She'd already been in prison for 20 years. And her lawyer felt she had been railroaded in terms of her conviction. And I should tell you, I knew nothing about this case. But the lawyer asked, would I be willing to look at her diaries? As it happened, she had kept diaries and there was a huge amount of entries. There were like 250 entries, tens of thousands of words that she had written. So they were quite extensive. And the lawyer wanted to know, is it possible to get a sense of her psychological state?
她已经在监狱里待了20年。她的律师觉得她在定罪方面受到了冤枉。我应该告诉你，我对这个案子一无所知。但律师问，我是否愿意看看她的日记？碰巧，她一直有写日记的习惯，而且条目数量巨大。大约有250个条目，她写了数万个字。所以它们非常详尽。律师想知道，是否有可能了解她的心理状态？
And so what happened was they ended up sending me all of her diaries that had been transcribed. And I went about analyzing them, trying to get a sense of just psychologically who she was, what was going on in her life. Was there any signs of instability? Were there any signs of hostility? Any signs of kind of premeditation
于是他们最终把她所有被转录的日记都发给了我。我开始分析它们，试图从心理学角度了解她是谁，她的生活中发生了什么。是否有任何不稳定的迹象？是否有任何敌意的迹象？是否有任何预谋的迹象
or anything like that. So that's the way I approached it. Now again, we talked earlier about how sometimes when lay people think about language and words, we're often very focused on is someone saying that they're happy, is someone saying they're sad, is someone saying they're anxious, is someone saying they're depressed.
或者类似的事情。这就是我处理它的方式。现在再次重申，我们之前谈到过，有时当外行思考语言和词汇时，我们通常非常关注某人是否说他们快乐，某人是否说他们悲伤，某人是否说他们焦虑，某人是否说他们抑郁。
Your approach has always been to sort of analyze more of these function words that are happening in some ways invisibly. And I'm imagining there probably were a lot of these function words if you had tens of thousands of words to work with. That's right. And I can also do a reasonably good job
你的方法一直是分析更多这些以某种方式隐形发生的功能词。我想象如果你有数万个词可以处理，可能有很多这样的功能词。没错。而且我也能做得相当好，
identifying big changes in psychological state. So for example, we have done some research on presidents who go to war or the Boston bomber in terms of his decision to blow things up. When people are planning to do something nefarious, what they often do is they start trying to act innocently, which is a hard thing to do. And what they do is they become more deceptive, they become less self-reflective, they are holding things back.
识别心理状态的重大变化。例如，我们对发动战争的总统或波士顿爆炸案嫌疑人关于他炸毁东西的决定做了一些研究。当人们计划做一些邪恶的事情时，他们经常做的是开始试图表现得无辜，这是一件很难做到的事情。他们变得更具欺骗性，变得不那么自我反思，他们有所保留。
Or if somebody is showing signs of deep depression, there are also markers of language. In other words, language can pick up if a person is becoming deceptive, if they're becoming depressed, if they're becoming manic, if there are major changes in their social behavior. All of these are available to us through the way they're using words. In one of your earlier studies, Jamie, you asked volunteers to come into the lab and make both true and false statements about their views on a hot button topic, in this case, abortion. And your computer program was able to detect people's true opinions 67% of the time, whereas human
或者如果某人表现出深度抑郁的迹象，也有语言标记。换句话说，如果一个人变得具有欺骗性，如果他们变得抑郁，如果他们变得躁狂，如果他们的社交行为发生了重大变化，语言可以捕捉到。所有这些都可以通过他们使用词汇的方式为我们所用。在你早期的研究之一中，杰米，你要求志愿者进入实验室，对一个热门话题（在这种情况下是堕胎）发表真实和虚假的陈述。你的计算机程序能够检测到人们真实意见的67%，而人类
judges got it right only 52% of the time. What were the language clues you were examining in this study? There were several, but the one that had the most potency were I words, I, me, and my. When somebody is telling the truth, they use I words. When a person is holding back or lying, they are hiding themselves and they suppress their use of eyes. So they're trying to get people to pay attention to something else or pay attention to some other event or object.
法官只有52%的时间做对了。你在这项研究中检查了哪些语言线索？有几个，但效力最强的是“我”类词汇——“我”、“我”和“我的”。当某人说真话时，他们使用“我”类词汇。当一个人有所保留或撒谎时，他们是在隐藏自己，他们抑制了“我”类词汇的使用。所以他们试图让人们关注其他事情，或者关注其他事件或物体。
In other words, we change the way we're paying attention and hopefully the way other people are paying attention when we're being deceptive. So again if language and words are reflecting what's happening inside our minds and I am trying to hide something, I'm actually trying to pay less attention to myself to change the focus and in some ways that comes out in the words and language we're using. I'm imagining that being able to tell whether people are being honest or they're lying is kind of useful when it comes to a murder investigation. It does. The big problem is there is no good method that's wildly reliable that can identify
换句话说，当我们进行欺骗时，我们改变了我们投入注意力的方式，并希望改变其他人投入注意力的方式。所以同样，如果语言和词汇反映了我们大脑内部正在发生的事情，而我试图隐藏某些东西，我实际上是在试图减少对自己的关注以转移焦点，在某种程度上，这体现在我们使用的词汇和语言中。我想象能够判断人们是否诚实或是否在撒谎在谋杀调查中很有用。确实有用。最大的问题是，没有一种非常可靠的方法可以识别
deception versus telling the truth. We can do better than chance, but we can't, there's no such thing as a great lie detector, and if anybody says they have one, be very, very careful. Right. I mean, in the study that we just talked about, the computer program was better than humans, but it was not perfect. It was not detecting dishonesty 100% of the time. That's correct. O, did she change in her language as it got closer to the child's death? Because if she was actually planning to kill the child, you would pick up a signal. There's no question about that. Her language was exactly the same as it had been for several weeks and months before.
欺骗与说真话。我们可以做得比随机猜测好，但我们不能，没有所谓的伟大的测谎仪，如果有人说他们有，要非常、非常小心。对。我的意思是，在我们刚才谈到的研究中，计算机程序比人类好，但它并不完美。它并没有100%的时间检测到不诚实。这是正确的。那么，随着孩子死亡时间的临近，她的语言发生了变化吗？因为如果她真的计划杀死孩子，你会收到一个信号。毫无疑问。她的语言与几周和几个月前完全一样。
And you would expect afterward changes there that might be associated with sadness or grief or maybe relief, but you know there wasn't much of a signal there either. Hmm. One of the things that you noticed is that after the death of her first son Caleb, Kathleen's diaries seem to repeat words at an extremely high rate. What was the conclusion you drew from this, Jamie? When people repeat, what they are doing is they are not paying attention to what they're saying. They're tripping over their words. They are consumed by other thoughts. And that can tell us all sorts of things. We'd have to ask ourselves,
你会期望之后会有与悲伤、痛苦或解脱相关的变化，但你知道，那里也没有太多的信号。嗯。你注意到的事情之一是，在她的第一个儿子凯莱布去世后，凯瑟琳的日记似乎以极高的频率重复词汇。你从中得出了什么结论，杰米？当人们重复时，他们所做的是他们没有关注他们在说什么。他们被自己的话绊倒了。他们被其他想法所消耗。这可以告诉我们各种各样的事情。我们必须问自己，
why are they not focusing on the topic? My guess was that she was, you know, really upset by the death of her child and then later her children. You could imagine having a child and then a second child and then a third die this way and no clear explanation for it. The wording was really sparse and there was this sense that she was just emotionally disengaged
为什么他们不关注这个话题？我的猜测是，她确实对孩子的死亡感到非常不安，后来是她的孩子。你可以想象有一个孩子，然后第二个孩子，然后第三个孩子以这种方式死去，而且没有明确的解释。措辞非常稀疏，有一种她只是情感上脱节的感觉，
and my sense was this was clearly a mark of postpartum depression, that she just wasn't psychologically connecting. In one of your studies that used tens of thousands of words as inputs, you found that about 10% of the words were what you called cognitive words, and in Kathleen's writings the average was much higher about 15%. What did this tell you about her mental state, Jimmy? So these words, cognitive process words, these are words like think, believe, wonder. And if you are nervous or concerned you hedge a lot more.
我的感觉是，这显然是产后抑郁症的标志，她只是在心理上没有连接。在你使用数万个词作为输入的研究之一中，你发现大约10%的词是你所说的认知词，而在凯瑟琳的写作中，平均值要高得多，大约15%。这告诉了你关于她心理状态的什么，杰米？所以这些词，认知过程词，这些是像“想”、“相信”、“怀疑”这样的词。如果你紧张或担心，你会更多地使用对冲词。
You don't say it's cold outside. You might say I You don't say, it's cold outside. You might say, I think it's perhaps, maybe it's cold outside. These words are common when people are ruminating or trying to work through issues. They're in a situation that they don't understand very well. They tend to be insecure. And all of us increase in those words
你不会说外面很冷。你可能会说“我”……你不会说，外面很冷。你可能会说，我想也许，可能外面很冷。当人们在反刍或试图解决问题时，这些词很常见。他们处于一种他们不太了解的情况中。他们往往缺乏安全感。我们所有人在
during periods like that. Now isn't it possible that rumination could have been a sign of guilt? It could be but I would say it more likely it's just a sign of uncertainty and confusion about life and it's interesting during her pregnancies and actually in her diaries throughout her diaries, her use of these cognitive words were high. And I think this was a marker of who she is. Hmm. We talked earlier about the use of I-words, words like I, me, and my. What did Kathleen's writings reveal about those words,
那样的时期都会增加这些词的使用。现在，反刍不可能是内疚的迹象吗？可能是，但我会说它更可能只是对生活的不确定和困惑的迹象，有趣的是，在她的怀孕期间，实际上在她的整个日记中，她对这些认知词的使用都很高。我认为这是她是谁的一个标志。嗯。我们之前谈到了“我”类词汇的使用，像“我”、“我”和“我的”这样的词。凯瑟琳的写作揭示了关于这些词的什么，
if any? Not much. Her I words were a little bit above average, but not much higher. And there weren't periods where they dropped a lot, which I would have expected had there been deception going on. And you know, at some points they were a little bit higher,
如果有的话？不多。她的“我”类词汇比平均水平高一点，但没有高出多少。而且没有出现大幅下降的时期，如果存在欺骗行为，我本会预料到这一点。你知道，在某些点上它们稍微高一点，
but that I think probably goes along with, I'm gonna guess kind of a residual anxiety and depression. But again, it wasn't so striking that I found that to be out of a normal range. So, taking all of this together, what were your conclusions about what actually happened in the Kathleen Folby case, Jamie? So, I felt the only thing that I could say was I didn't see high rates of anything that
但我认为这可能伴随着，我猜是一种残留的焦虑和抑郁。但同样，它并不那么引人注目，以至于我发现它超出了正常范围。所以，综合所有这些，你对凯瑟琳·福尔比格案中实际发生的事情有什么结论，杰米？所以，我觉得我唯一能说的是，我没有看到任何高频率的
would suggest levels of anger or hostility. That was not true in anything that I saw. Her anxiety levels and negative emotion words were a little above average, but they weren't off the charts. I saw no signs of deception. She was remarkably stable across her her writing. I think what you saw is what you get with her. From my perspective there was nothing there that would raise any red flags. To be clear, Jamie did not conclude that Kathleen was innocent. He only concluded that if she had killed her children, her writing style would probably have reflected her inner storms.
暗示愤怒或敌意水平的东西。我在我看到的任何东西中都不是真的。她的焦虑水平和负面情绪词汇比平均水平高一点，但它们并没有超出图表。我没有看到任何欺骗的迹象。她在她的写作中非常稳定。我认为你看到的就是你得到的。从我的角度来看，没有任何东西会引起任何危险信号。需要明确的是，杰米并没有得出凯瑟琳是无辜的结论。他只是得出结论，如果她杀死了她的孩子，她的写作风格可能会反映出她内心的风暴。
His analysis did not find evidence for such storms. Jamie's report was one of two new pieces of scientific evidence in the case. Besides getting a language analysis from Jamie, Kathleen Folbig's lawyers enlisted scientists to sequence her DNA and the DNA of her children. They discovered an extremely rare genetic mutation that is linked to a heightened risk of sudden death in infancy. The appeals court judges considered that evidence, along with Jamie's findings in Kathleen's diaries. Two decades after Kathleen's original conviction,
他的分析没有发现这种风暴的证据。杰米的报告是该案中两项新的科学证据之一。除了从杰米那里获得语言分析外，凯瑟琳·福尔比格的律师还招募了科学家来对她的DNA和她孩子的DNA进行测序。他们发现了一种极其罕见的基因突变，这与婴儿猝死的高风险有关。上诉法院法官考虑了该证据，以及杰米在凯瑟琳日记中的发现。在凯瑟琳最初被定罪二十年后，
they reached a new conclusion about the case. Kathleen's lawyers gave Jamie a link to watch the court proceedings. And so I watched this very formal proceeding, everybody in these very fanciful robes. The Chief Justice gets up and he reads this brief discussion of the case. In relation to the diary entries, it may readily be understood how certain entries viewed in isolation had a powerful influence on the original
他们对该案得出了新的结论。凯瑟琳的律师给了杰米一个链接来观看法庭诉讼。所以我观看了这个非常正式的程序，每个人都穿着这些非常奇特的法袍。首席大法官站起来，他读了这份关于案件的简短讨论。关于日记条目，可以很容易地理解某些条目在孤立地看待时是如何对最初的定罪产生强大影响的。
jury in a manner adverse to Miss Folbig. Viewed in their full context however as they must be and informed by the expert psychological and psychiatric expert evidence referred to extensively in the report, the diary entries were not reliable admissions of guilt. Thus while the verdicts at trial were reasonably open on the evidence then available, there is now reasonable doubt as to Ms. Fulvig's guilt. And then he says the court unanimously agrees that she should be exonerated. It is appropriate that Ms. Fulvig's conviction be quashed. The court so orders and directs the entry of verdicts of acquittal.
陪审团对福尔比格女士不利。然而，正如必须的那样，从其完整背景来看，并参考报告中广泛引用的专家心理学和精神病学证据，日记条目并非可靠的认罪供词。因此，虽然审判时的判决在当时可用的证据下是合理的，但现在对福尔比格女士的罪行存在合理怀疑。然后他说，法院一致同意她应该被平反。撤销福尔比格女士的定罪是恰当的。法院据此下令并指示作出无罪判决。
The court will now adjourn. And I remember watching that and tears coming down my eyes. And even as I'm telling you this, I get really, I get really choked up. Hmm. I mean, in some ways, it really points to the power of this research. I mean, it's obviously fascinating in its own right at an intellectual level, but really, this is an example of where the real world effects of this research are potentially transformative. It really is, and it just makes me proud to be able to make some kind of contribution to something like this. Most of us are not asked to investigate a string of strange and potentially sinister
法院现在休庭。我记得看着那一幕，眼泪夺眶而出。即使现在我告诉你这些，我也感到非常哽咽。嗯。我的意思是，在某些方面，这确实指出了这项研究的力量。我的意思是，它在智力层面上本身显然就很迷人，但实际上，这是一个现实世界中这项研究的影响具有潜在变革性的例子。确实如此，能够为这样的事情做出某种贡献让我感到自豪。我们大多数人不会被要求调查一系列奇怪且潜在险恶的
deaths, but all of us constantly evaluate the mind states of others. When we come back, what language can reveal about students' performance in college and what it can tell us about whether our romantic relationships are going to last? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Every day, the words we use reflect who we are. Language is the medium through which we communicate our innermost thoughts and feelings. Psychologist James Pennebaker has studied how the words we use can reveal things about our love lives. Jamie, you once studied people who were on speed dates.
死亡事件，但我们所有人都在不断评估他人的心理状态。回来后，语言能揭示学生在大学里的表现，以及它能告诉我们我们的浪漫关系是否会持久吗？您正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。每天，我们使用的词汇都反映了我们是谁。语言是我们交流内心深处思想和感受的媒介。心理学家詹姆斯·彭尼贝克研究了我们使用的词汇如何揭示我们爱情生活中的事情。杰米，你曾经研究过参加快速约会的人。
You recorded their conversations with potential mates and then transcribed them. What were you looking for and what did you find? What had happened was I had never been interested in studying speed dates but there had been a wonderful study done out of Northwestern. Eli Finkel and his colleagues, Paul Eastwick and others had done some speed dates where they brought these were heterosexual speed dates, they brought men and women in and each person would talk to multiple other people and then afterwards they would rate each person and they were trying to find out which people were likely to go on a date subsequently. So the study was published and one of my graduate students, Molly Ireland, told me about the study
你记录了他们与潜在伴侣的对话，然后将其转录下来。你在寻找什么，又发现了什么？事情是这样的，我从未对研究快速约会感兴趣，但西北大学做了一项很棒的研究。伊莱·芬克尔和他的同事保罗·伊斯特威克等人进行了一些快速约会，他们带来了——这些是异性恋快速约会，他们带来了男人和女人，每个人都会与多个人交谈，然后事后他们会给每个人打分，他们试图找出哪些人可能会在随后去约会。所以这项研究发表了，我的一位研究生莫莉·爱尔兰告诉了我这项研究
and she and I were studying something that we called language style matching, a degree which two people's language connect with each other, that they use pronouns at similar levels, articles, prepositions, et cetera. And we wondered, would this be related to the speed dating? So Molly contacted the Northwestern group, asking, would it be possible for us to analyze their data to see if the language of these people in the speed dates
我和她正在研究一种我们称之为语言风格匹配的东西，即两个人的语言相互连接的程度，他们使用代词、冠词、介词等的水平相似。我们想知道，这是否与快速约会有关？所以莫莉联系了西北大学的小组，询问我们是否有可能分析他们的数据，看看这些人在快速约会中的语言
could predict whether or not they'd go out on a subsequent date? And what we discovered was that if you looked at how much the two people matched in their language style, we did a pretty decent job at predicting who would subsequently go out on a date. Specifically, we did better than the people themselves in predicting if they'd go out on a date. And of course, one reason is, is very often you get one person who said,
能否预测他们是否会进行后续约会？我们发现，如果你观察这两个人在语言风格上的匹配程度，我们在预测谁会进行后续约会方面做得相当不错。具体来说，我们在预测他们是否会去约会方面比他们自己做得更好。当然，原因之一是，通常你会遇到一个人说，
wow, that date went great. And the other person said, not so much. And what happens is this style matching is a marker of the degree to which the two of them really are on the same page, that they're clicking. In some ways you told me earlier, Jamie, that there were differences between men and women in terms of the language they used, the words they used, especially the function words they used. In some ways, especially I think with heterosexual speed dating, it does raise questions, doesn't it? Because in some ways, this research is suggesting that the closer people are, the more likely they are to go out on dates. And the earlier research had found
哇，那次约会太棒了。而另一个人说，没那么好。发生的情况是，这种风格匹配是两人是否真的合拍、是否产生共鸣的一个标志。在某些方面，你之前告诉我，杰米，男人和女人在使用的语言、使用的词汇，尤其是使用的功能词方面存在差异。在某些方面，尤其是考虑到异性恋快速约会，这确实引发了问题，不是吗？因为在某些方面，这项研究表明人们越亲近，他们去约会的可能性就越大。而早期的研究发现
that in general, men and women often use different kinds of words. It doesn't portend well, I suppose, for most speed daters. You know, I think we have to think about how conversations work. That sometimes I'll speak like a professor, sometimes I speak like a lover, sometimes I speak like a father. And my language changes in all those situations. And if I'm going on a speed date and I'm really interested in the other person, I will start to talk like them. And if they're really interested in me,
总的来说，男人和女人经常使用不同种类的词汇。我想，这对大多数快速约会者来说并不是一个好兆头。你知道，我认为我们必须思考对话是如何运作的。有时我会像教授一样说话，有时我会像恋人一样说话，有时我会像父亲一样说话。在所有这些情况下，我的语言都会改变。如果我去参加快速约会，并且我真的对对方感兴趣，我会开始像他们一样说话。如果他们真的对我感兴趣，
they'll start talking like me, and the two of us will come together in a way that we might not do under different circumstances. Interesting. You've also done a follow-up study featuring college freshman couples, and you look to see the text exchanges
他们会开始像我一样说话，我们两人会以一种在不同情况下可能不会有的方式走到一起。有趣。你还做了一项后续研究，以大学新生情侣为对象，你观察了他们之间的短信交流
they had with one another as a potential predictor of whether the couples would still be together three months down the road. So this would be using language in some ways as a predictor for how long relationships might last. Tell me about the study and what you found. So this was a study that one of my former students, Rich Slatcher, did, and it was a wonderful study where he was able to find young couples that were dating. They had to have been together a certain amount of time, and they had to agree to give 10
作为情侣三个月后是否还会在一起的潜在预测指标。所以这在某种程度上是使用语言作为关系能持续多久的预测指标。告诉我这项研究以及你的发现。这是我的一位前学生里奇·斯莱彻所做的一项研究，这是一项很棒的研究，他能够找到正在约会的年轻情侣。他们必须在一起一定的时间，并且他们必须同意提供10
days of their instant messages or their text messages to us to analyze. We went through and we analyzed the degree to which the two people in their text messages were matching in terms of this language style matching. And then we used that to find out would this predict how long the relationship lasted. What we found was that we could split the couples in terms of their language style matching scores were above average or below average. And those that were above average, almost 80 percent were still together three months later. And those that were in the bottom half of style matching, only about half of them were still together three months later. In other words, here is an interesting marker of the quality of their relationship, but
天的即时消息或短信供我们分析。我们通读并分析了这两个人在短信中进行这种语言风格匹配的程度。然后我们用它来找出这是否能预测关系持续了多久。我们发现，我们可以根据语言风格匹配得分高于平均水平还是低于平均水平来划分情侣。那些高于平均水平的人，近80%在三个月后仍然在一起。而那些风格匹配处于后半部分的人，只有大约一半在三个月后仍然在一起。换句话说，这是衡量他们关系质量的一个有趣的标志，但
the thing that was most interesting was it was completely unrelated to their self-reports. We had asked them beforehand, how strong is your relationship, how likely is it you think you'll be together in the next six months, etc. And it turns out their judgment to their relationship was completely unrelated to whether or not they were still together three months later. This language style matching, however, was a really good predictor of it. You've also studied couples who have broken up,
最有趣的事情是它与他们的自我报告完全无关。我们事先问过他们，你们的关系有多牢固，你们认为未来六个月在一起的可能性有多大，等等。结果发现，他们对关系的判断与三个月后他们是否还在一起完全无关。然而，这种语言风格匹配确实是一个很好的预测指标。你还研究过分手的情侣，
and this was a study that involved the social media site Reddit. What did you do and what did you find, Jamie? This was the first study that really introduced me to the power of social media. Reddit is a particularly interesting source because tens of thousands of people go there and they will often write about how they have recently broken up. The majority have been dumped by somebody else and sometimes they get you know emotional support from others sometimes they just want to reveal it. The average person actually had posted
这是一项涉及社交媒体网站Reddit的研究。你做了什么，发现了什么，杰米？这是第一项真正让我认识到社交媒体力量的研究。Reddit是一个特别有趣的来源，因为成千上万的人去那里，他们经常会写下他们最近是如何分手的。大多数人被别人甩了，有时他们会得到（你知道）他人的情感支持，有时他们只是想倾诉。普通人实际上已经发布了
between one and a few times in the breakup subreddit and they'd posted over a hundred times and all these other subreddits in the breakup subreddit, and they'd posted over 100 times in all these other subreddits in the months before and the months after. And we got all of their posts in all of their subreddits from the year before the breakup to the year afterwards. And what we found was that in the months before, starting about three months before the breakup, their language starts to change. They become more anxious, they start using more I words, their cognitive process words
在分手子版块发布了一到几次，而在所有其他子版块发布了一百多次，在分手子版块，他们在分手前后的几个月里在所有其他子版块发布了超过100次。我们获取了他们从分手前一年到分手后一年在所有子版块中的所有帖子。我们发现，在分手前的几个月里，大约从分手前三个月开始，他们的语言开始发生变化。他们变得更加焦虑，开始更多地使用“我”这个词，他们的认知过程词汇
go up, they become less logical and formal in their language, less structured, almost as though they're under increasing amounts of stress. And then they have their breakup and they post about it. And at this point, they are low in logical thinking, their anxiety and negative emotions are high, their I-words are high. And then the after effects, we can track lasting six months. People going through a breakup are profoundly affected. They are not good at work. They even talk about how they're making errors,
增加，他们在语言上变得不那么合乎逻辑和正式，结构性变差，几乎就像他们承受着越来越大的压力。然后他们分手了，并发布了相关内容。此时，他们的逻辑思维能力较低，焦虑和负面情绪较高，“我”字使用率较高。然后是后遗症，我们可以追踪到持续六个月。经历分手的人会受到深刻影响。他们工作表现不佳。他们甚至谈论他们是如何犯错的，
they're coming in late, they're drinking too much, et cetera. It really gave me a different perspective. But in some ways, Jamie, what you're finding is that language is both a predictor of when a relationship might come apart, and then it also in some ways is an X-ray into what's happening in people's minds after a relationship comes apart. That's exactly
他们迟到，喝太多酒等等。这确实给了我一个不同的视角。但在某些方面，杰米，你的发现是，语言既是关系何时可能破裂的预测指标，在某种程度上也是关系破裂后人们内心发生什么的X光片。完全正确，
right and one thing that was interesting was how many people when they were writing about their breakup they would say this came out of nowhere I had no expectation. Yeah. But I think they kind of did. You know, their numbers showed that they were thinking differently. They were orienting their lives in a different way in those months beforehand. You've also done some really unusual work predicting how successful students are going to be in college based on their college admission essays. Tell me about that work, Jamie. When people apply to universities, they write an admissions essay. And I was curious, would it be possible to analyze their admissions
而且有一件事很有趣，那就是当人们写到他们的分手时，有多少人会说这突如其来，我没有任何预料。是的。但我认为他们其实是有预料的。你知道，他们的数据显示，在之前的几个月里，他们的思维方式不同了。他们以不同的方式规划自己的生活。你还做了一些非常不寻常的工作，根据大学入学论文预测学生在大学里会取得多大的成功。告诉我那项工作，杰米。当人们申请大学时，他们会写一篇入学论文。我很好奇，是否有可能分析他们的入学
essays and see if it would predict how well they would do at the university? So working with our admissions office, I was able to analyze about 50,000 admissions essays from 25,000 students who enrolled at the university. And we were curious, were there features of language in their admissions essays that could tell us something? We discovered that there was this group of words, these are all function words, that naturally hang together in an interesting way. We now call it analytic thinking. If you are thinking in an analytic way, you're thinking in a logical, formal,
论文并看看它是否能预测他们在大学里的表现？因此，与我们的招生办公室合作，我能够分析25,000名入学学生的大约50,000篇入学论文。我们很好奇，他们的入学论文中是否有语言特征能告诉我们一些事情？我们发现有一组词，这些都是功能词，它们以一种有趣的方式自然地结合在一起。我们现在称之为分析性思维。如果你以分析的方式思考，你就是在以逻辑、正式、
hierarchical way. You're using lots of articles and nouns and prepositions, but you're not using many pronouns or auxiliary verbs. And what we found was that the more analytic a person's essay was, the better they did at the university. So four years later, people who were high in their analytic essays, they made better grades Whether they were in the business school philosophy nursing fine arts. It didn't matter I'm wondering Jamie after doing all this work. Do you find yourself? You know perusing people's language as work, do you find yourself, you know,
层级的方式思考。你使用大量的冠词、名词和介词，但你不使用太多的代词或助动词。我们发现，一个人的论文越具有分析性，他们在大学里的表现就越好。所以四年后，那些分析性论文得分高的人，他们取得了更好的成绩。无论他们是在商学院、哲学系、护理系还是美术系。这并不重要。杰米，在做了所有这些工作后，我想知道。你是否发现自己？你知道，在工作中仔细研读人们的语言，你是否发现自己，你知道，
perusing people's language as they talk to you or write to you? Do you find that as you're reviewing emails from friends, you can't help but say, you know, huh, that's an unusual number of pronouns and prepositions? Usually not. And it's always funny, but I give a talk on this, you know, I can tell people are so self-conscious. Here's the good news. People can't tell unless you talk in a weird way. And you can't believe how many emails that I've gotten over the years.
在他们与你交谈或写信给你时仔细研读人们的语言？当你查看朋友的电子邮件时，你是否发现自己忍不住说，你知道，嗯，代词和介词的数量不寻常？通常不会。这总是很有趣，但我做了一个关于这个的演讲，你知道，我可以看出人们非常自我意识。好消息是：除非你说话的方式很奇怪，否则人们看不出来。你无法相信我多年来收到了多少电子邮件。
Dear Dr. Pennebaker, just wanted to say the work you do is good. Thinking about such and such, and they'll have no first person singular pronouns. And I'm thinking, why? And then sometimes someone at the end will say, it took me an hour to write this email so I didn't use any I words. And what it does is it makes them sound deranged.
亲爱的彭尼贝克博士，只是想说你所做的工作很好。思考某某某，他们不会使用任何第一人称单数代词。我在想，为什么？然后有时有人在最后会说，我花了一个小时写这封邮件，所以我没有使用任何“我”字。这让听起来很疯狂。
Psychologist James Pennebaker is the author of the secret life of pronouns, What Our Words Say About Us. Jamie, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a joy. Thank you. My My I Me My Be my I
心理学家詹姆斯·彭尼贝克是《代词的秘密生活：我们的词汇如何说明我们自己》一书的作者。杰米，非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。这真是一种乐趣。谢谢。我的，我的，我，我，我的，是我的，我
Me Me My One of the unusual things about Jamie Pennebaker is that he is responsible for two major discoveries in the course of his psychology research career. We've talked about the first in today's show. In our companion story, we explore the other dimension of Jamie's work on the power of what he calls expressive writing to help us think through difficult challenges in our lives. If you have ever
我，我的。杰米·彭尼贝克不寻常的一点是，他在心理学研究生涯中做出了两项重大发现。我们在今天的节目中讨论了第一个。在我们的配套故事中，我们探索了杰米工作的另一个维度，即他所说的表达性写作的力量，以帮助我们思考生活中困难的挑战。如果你曾经
experienced a breakup or lost a job or suffered a serious illness, that episode is for you. Jimmy has found surprising and unusual effects that come from expressive writing, but he has also found that some kinds of writing have psychological benefits, while other forms have no effects or can even be harmful. I learned a lot from that conversation. I think you will too. To listen to it now, please go to the episode titled Dear Diary in our subscription feed, Hidden Brain Plus. If you are not yet a subscriber, please go to apple.co. slash hiddenbrain on your iOS device.
经历过分手、失业或患过重病，那一集就是为你准备的。杰米发现了表达性写作带来的令人惊讶和不寻常的效果，但他也发现某些类型的写作具有心理益处，而其他形式则没有效果甚至可能有害。我从那次谈话中学到了很多。我想你也会。要立即收听，请前往我们订阅源《隐藏的大脑Plus》中标题为“亲爱的日记”的剧集。如果你还不是订阅者，请在你的iOS设备上访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。
If you're using another kind of phone or tablet, you can sign up via our Patreon page at support.hiddenbrain.org. In either case, you can get a free 7-day trial. Your support helps us build more episodes like this. If you're already a supporter, thank you. You have immediate access to the Dear Diary episode right now. Again, if you'd like to give the subscription a try,
如果你使用的是其他类型的手机或平板电脑，你可以通过我们的Patreon页面support.hiddenbrain.org注册。无论哪种方式，你都可以获得7天的免费试用。你的支持帮助我们制作更多像这样的剧集。如果你已经是支持者，谢谢。你现在可以立即访问“亲爱的日记”剧集。再次重申，如果你想尝试订阅，
please visit apple.co. slash hiddenbrain or support.hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
请访问apple.co/hiddenbrain或support.hiddenbrain.org。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Special thanks to Liza Gutstein Katz for voice acting and singing in this week's episode. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
特别感谢丽莎·古特斯坦·卡茨在本周的剧集中担任配音和演唱。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。